merci et notre invité ce matin c'est
Thierry Breton bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous thier breton
commissaire européen au Marché intérieur
on est ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour
une interview en partenariat avec la
presse régionale représenté par Stéphane
Vernet de wouest France bonjour Stéphane
bonjour Bron bonjour B bonjour Thierry
Breton on va commencer par parler de ce
qui s'est passé hier à Davos où était
Emmanuel Macron le président de la
République qui a appelé l'Europe à tenir
le choc de l'accélération du monde il a
dit l'Europe est face à de très grande
difficultés dans cette réorganisation du
monde est-ce qu'elle est suffisamment
armée l'Europe pour vous l'Europe de
plus en plus est un continent qui
réalise évidemment ce qui se passe qui
se passe autour de lui on a pas attendu
évidemment je dirais les dernières
nouvelles les dernières nouvelles aux
États-Unis les dernières nouvelles
également en Ukraine voir en Chine
l'Europe doit prendre son destin en main
et on ne cesse de le dire le président
de la République l'avait rappelé du
reste à son discours de la Sorbonne
moi-même en tant que commissaire depuis
maintenant plus de 4 ans c'est mon
travail de faire en sorte que
effectivement l'Europe reprenne son
desant en main comprennent aussi et
fassent comprendre à l'ensemble de nos
concitoyens européens que nous sommes un
continent de plus en plus fort puissant
non pas puissant parce que on veut
imposer notre puissance aux autres mais
tout simplement pour protéger nos nos
concitoyens dans le monde tel qu'il est
alors à votre question il faut bien sûr
augmenter notre capacité à accroître
cette puissance dans tous les domaines
dans les domaines industriels avec la
réindustrialisation dans le domaine
numérique avec tout ce qu'on a fait dans
ce domaine de façon extrêmement
vigoureuse et puis évidemment en ce qui
concerne la défense l'Europe dépense
aujourd'hui quand on additionne tous les
États-membres de 100 milliards d'euros
par an mais on le fait encore de façon
trop dispersée il faut augmenter nos
capacités de défense il faut augmenter
la capacité de le faire ensemble et
c'est aussi tout mon travail et et
justement on va en parler juste un un
dernier mot mais c'est un rapport avec
ce que vous venez de dire Emmanuel
Macron hier il a appelé les Européens à
émettre à nouveau de la dette commune
pour investir dans les priorités
d'avenir est-ce que les Européens vont
suivre selon vous est-ce que ça restera
un V pieux non vous savez on l'a vu avec
toutes les les crises que nous avons
affronté j'allais dire les unes après
les autres au cours des derniers années
euh personne ne s'attendait à à à la
crise de la covid on a réussi à trouver
les moyens pour lutter contre pour
devenir en quelques mois du reste la
pharmacie Du Monde vacciner l'ensemble
de nos concitoyens mais aussi plus de
100 pays on a su trouver les moyens de
résister aux conséquences et notamment
aux conséquences économiques et sociales
avec le programme next generation eu où
effectivement nous avons émis de la
dette en commun pour protéger l'ensemble
du du secteur économique des fermetures
administratives j'allais dire qui était
la conséquence du covid on a su trouver
les moyens également pour la crise de
l'énergie conséquence de l'agression de
Vladimir Poutine en Russie donc donc là
ça veut dire que les les les
États-membres sont prêts à nouveau à
suivre
emmanu mon message c'est que l'Europe
elle fonctionne de mieux en mieux en
ayant conscience des problèmes à
affronter
euh en se donnant ensuite les moyens de
les surmonter donc le problème
maintenant il est clair le problème et
notamment ce qui concerne la défense
c'est l'agression de Vladimir Poutine en
Ukraine on le sait c'est évidemment
l'Ukraine évidemment qui est en première
ligne de façon absolument admirable mais
c'est nous qui sommes en seconde ligne
c'est nous qui sommes visés donc oui
bien sûr il faut augmenter notre
capacité d'industrie de défense ensemble
et c'est tout le projet que je porte
alors avec une vision peut-être de j'ai
évoqué une centaine de milliards d'euros
qu'il faudrait peut-être mettre sur la
table si les États-membres sont d'accord
on serura trouvver les moyens vousz
évoqué une centaine de milliards d'euros
pour relancer le l'industrie de
l'armement en Europe la somme est très
très conséquente vous avez même suggéré
l'idée de la création d'un porteavion
Européen est-ce que est-ce que tout ça
est réaliste et et vous venez de dire à
l'instant s'il y a la volonté la
politique les États-membres suivront
êtes-vous bien sûr que les 27 puissent
vous vous suivre sur ce terrain vous
savez lorsque j'ai lancé l'idée d'avoir
une constellation souveraine qui
permette de faire de la connectivité
sécurisée y compris pour pour être
présente sur les terraines d'opération
j'étais tout seul et puis on a on a
progressivement bâti bâti ce projet et
convaincu les 27 au début il était tout
seul lorsque le président de la
République lance cette idée de de
souveraineté il est tout seul et puis
progressivement et bien on bâtit lorsque
l'on dit que il faut faut désormais nous
donner les moyens je vais élargir votre
question de protéger nos espaces
contestés c'est ça dont il s'agit l'
espaces contestés pour nos
téléspectateurs sont des espaces qui
sont des tat d'opération mais qui sont
pas des espaces territoriaux on pense
évidemment à à à l'espace cyber vous
mettez la guerre hybride autour de
l'information dans C espace cont voà
voilà on pense bien entendu à l'espace
tout court il y a l'espace maritime
aussi on sait que l'Europe dispose de la
plus grande zone d'exclusivité maritime
au monde ces espaces contestés il faut
les protéger en étant mutualisé il y a
pas un pays en Europe qui peut protéger
son petit bout d'espace audessus de son
territoire il y a pas un pays en Europe
qui peut protéger seul son petit bout
d'espace cyber parce quement nous sommes
tous maintenant j'allais dire
interconnectés et donc dans le Livre
blanc européen de la défense qu'on
appelle notre boussole stratégique qui a
été déjà arrêté l'ensemble des 27 on dit
que sur ces espaces là il fallait qu'on
se protège ensemble on est en train de
travailler sur
des socs c'està-dire des des des des
lieux des des des cyber calculateurs
pour pouvoir protéger et anticiper le
dépasse cyber et avoir un dô de
cybécurité ensemble grâce à la
constellation iris dont j'ai parlé on va
pouvoir protéger l'espace de l'espace il
faudra aussi se poser la question un
jour de des moyens à mettre pour
protéger notre espace maritime c'est
évidemment des ambitions c'est une
vision mais si on n' pas cette en vision
commune je pense que d'abord on ne fait
pas ce qu'il y a à faire président la
répuique l'a dit l'Europe risque d'être
très très affectée donc oui il faut être
ambitieux les temps nous appelle
aujourd'hui à cette ambition alors
l'étant nous appelle à cette ambition il
y a aussi une urgence selon vous on voit
par exemple il est il est il est de
l'ordre du possible que que Donald Trump
soit réélu aux États-Unis à l'automne à
l'automne prochain vous aviez révélé il
y a quelques temps que lors d'une
conversation lorsqu'il était président
lors d'une une conversation qu'il avait
eu avec des dirigeants européens dont
vous-même et le le président président
américain avait évoqué sa volonté de de
mettre fin à l'OTAN de de de de laisser
tomber l'Alliance atlantique est-ce que
si Donald Trump revenait aux manettes
aujourd'hui aux États-Unis il pourrait
vraiment mettre fin à l'OTAN alors bien
sûr on a tous suivi vous avez commenter
ce qui s'est passé l'occasion du cocus
de l'ayowa où effectivement Donald Trump
a emporté j'allais dire très haut la
main ce ce cocus donc il est aujourd'hui
clairement candidat désigné en tout cas
à l'investiture il semble qu'il fasse la
course en tête donc oui il est il est
aujourd'hui euh clairement euh
potentiellement euh le futur président
des États-Unis bien sûr les élections
n'ont pas eu lieu euh mais effectivement
il est aujourd'hui dans la course vous
l'avez rappelé alors maintenant en ce
qui concerne les prises de position de
Donald Trump en tant que président ou ou
après alors il a son il a son phrasé
hein vous le commmentez assez souvent
j'ai été donc témoin de ce phrasé sur un
thème sur un thème du reste qu'il avait
développé pas uniquement en présence du
la vanlan et moi-même c'était l'anecdote
que que je rappelais mais à plusieurs
reprises sur le fait que il n'était pas
je dirais un visiblement un fanatique de
de l'aant en tout qu' il l'avait dit à
l'époque et que il demandit instamment
avec ses mots à ce que l'Europe prenne
davantage son des en main et notamment
en ce qui concerne sa sécurité et sa
défense voilà donc euh c'est pas une
surprise c'est vrai que
euh lorsqu'il le dit euh c'est commême
le président des
États-Unis c'est un c'est un élément
mais encore une fois il l'a dit à mat
reprise qu'est-ce que ça veut dire pour
nous ça veut dire de toute façon que
quel que soit le je dirais le le
résultat des élections américaines je
rappelle que le président Obama avant
lui avait dit de de façon extrêmement
claire demander de façon extrêmement
claire aux Européens que désormais il
fassent beaucoup plus d'effort en
matière de de défense ça veut dire que
oui nous devons prendre notre destin en
main et oui nous devons augmenter nos
investissements en matière de défense
vous savez du reste l'ensemble des
États-membres qui sont membres de l'OTAN
c'est-à-dire quasiment tous ont pris
désormais enfin l'engagement de dépenser
2 % de leurs produits intérieur Brit en
matière de dépenses militaires c'est euh
un prix réquisite je le rappelle pour
les membres de l'OTAN c'est pas le cas
grand à part la France à part à part la
Grèce très peu y été vous pensez qu'il
est atignable cet objectif al en tout
cas ils ont pris l'engagement je suis
très heureux du reste que nos voisins
allemands et et enfin décidé de prendre
cet cet engagement ils sont ils étaient
assez loin de de de la cible et c'est
vrai avait donné quelque fois le le
sentiment parmi d'autres du reste je
pense en particulier à certains pays
aussi l'ancien bloc de l'Est de saabiter
derrière ce parapluie américain voilà on
sait désormais que ce parapluie
américain il est ce qu'il est le
président Obama avait de demander à ce
que chacun prenne ses responsabilités
donc c'est je dirais que c'est une
constante B il faut que pour nous on en
tire les leçons si tous les pays pour
nos téléspectateurs si tous les pays les
états- membres membres de l'OTAN en
Europe montent effectivement à 2 %
conformément à l'engagement qu'ils ont
désormais tous pris avec un calendrier
dans les années qui viennent c'est 143
milliards d'euros de plus qui seront
investis chaque année en matière de
défense donc voilà mon travail aussi
c'est de faire sorte que la base
industrielle européenne de défense
augmente ses capacités parce
qu'évidemment ce qu'on souhaite d'abord
c'est qu'on qu'on réalise effectivement
cette décision qu'on la mette en œuvre
mais aussi que ceci bénéficie à nos
industries et derrière aussi à nos
emplois je vais reformulé ma question
autrement de manière beaucoup plus
directe si imaginons que si demain les
États-Unis décidaient de laisser tomber
l'Ukraine tout aide à l'Ukraine est-ce
que l'Europe est prête à prendre le
relais d'ù l'urgence sur les questions
de défense de réarmement mais vous savez
d'abord le
l'Europe a dépensé un peu plus que les
que les États-Unis pour soutenir
l'Ukraine tout secteur confondu on
l'oublie on l'oublie je le redis le
président de la République l'a
ditula van derlen l'a dit Charles Michel
le président du Conseil européen l'a dit
également c'est notre destin qui est qui
est en jeu et et et nous l'avons tous
dit donc on fera ce qu'il faut pour
évidemment défendre défendre l'Ukraine
alors je je juste un point pour finir ça
passe évidemment en matière de défense
par une augmentation extrêmement rapide
et significative de notre base
industrielle on sait tout faire en
matière de défense en Europe on sait
tout faire on sait faire les missiles
les plus sophistiqués les missiles
hypersoniques les sous-marins des
sous-marins nucléaires des porte-avions
des porteavions nucléaires les avions
les plus de combat les plus
perfectionnés les chars les plus
modernes on sait tout faire le problème
c'est que il faut qu'on le fasse
maintenant plus vite et donc qu'on
augmente notre capacité industrielle
c'est tout projet que je porte on va en
discuter du
reste à l'occasion du prochain Conseil
européen du 1er février nous
présenterons nous-même du reste à à son
invitation donc une une communication
très avancée sur les voies et moyens
pour augmenter notre capacité de défense
à la fin du mois de de février donc
voilà on c'est pas parce qu'il y a des
élections qu'on ralenti je dirais au
contraire on accélère ce matin dans le
Parisien Sébastien Cornu ministre des
Armées annonce la production de 70 canon
César à destination de l'Ukraine et il
dit en incitant les Européens et nos
alliés à se partager cette facture la
France amorcera le financement pour
entraîner les autres est-ce que les
autres vont suivre oui il y a vraiment
une volonté je vous savez je je je suis
en permanence en const en discussion
avec eux je par je pars je serai ce soir
à
Vilnius demain à
talin la semaine prochaine je serai en
Pologne et puis ensuite de
nouveau en Ukraine à l'invitation du
président Zelenski parce parce que
vraiment je tiens à le dire il y a
vraiment aujourd'hui une vraie une vraie
prise de
conscience de la nécessité
d'accroître notre support à l'Ukraine
mais je le redis de façon très claire ça
passe par une augmentation de notre base
industrielle de défense il faut
augmenter les
cadences on a parlé président de la
République souvent du reste à juste
titre la nécessité de passer entre
guillemets dans une sorte d'économie de
guerre pour les industries de défense il
faut augmenter les cadences les usines
sont là les lieux de fabrication sont là
il faut se veiller à ce que les
compétences évidemment suivent et puis à
ce que nous ayons aussi l'ensemble des
chaînes de valeur on sa en particulier
dans les munitions et bien il faut de la
poudre il faut un certain nombre de
composants qu'il faut il faut augmenter
la production significative c'est tout
ça qui est en route aujourd'hui les les
étatsmembres peuvent aider l'Ukraine
jusqu'à quand mais les
États-membres ont tous dit avec leur mot
alors évidemment la Hongrie le dit un
peu différemment mais vous savez euh
chacun joue aussi sa partition la la
Hongrie augmente aussi et je peux
emporter témoignage de façon très
importante sa capacité de production
d'armement et et et et et le permettra
de de de vendre sa production à à
d'autres pays européens qui font ce
qu'ils voudront ensuite donc vous voyez
on a vraiment aujourd'hui cette volonté
d'accélération je la vois partout il
faut maintenant la coordonner il faut
aussi avoir les les moyens pour le faire
l'initiative qu'a rappelé le ministre
euh de la défense ce matin dans le
Parisien va évidemment évidemment dans
le dans le bon sens et et on ne peut que
s'en féliciter Emmanuel Macron mardi il
a annoncé de nouvelles livraisons de
missiles de bombes est-ce que la
question de l'envoi de moyens aériens va
se reposer pour vous la question en tout
cas elle a été elle a été clairement
posée par par le président zéenski après
ça euh moi je suis commissaire européin
donc je ne parle pas au nom des états
euh chaque État ensuite se positionne
ombre d'État euh euh ont répondu euh
favorablement à cette demande d'abord
vous vous en souvenez et on l'a un peu
oublié avec la dotation d'un nombre
important de euh d'avions d'aéronef euh
qui euh était issu de du monde
soviétique beaucoup des pays beaucoup de
ces pays de rest de nos pays d'Europe
sont encore dotés de façon dans le
armement euh euh d'armement qui date de
cette période c'est le cas aussi de
l'Ukraine majoritairement en particulier
pour son aviation et donc il y a déjà eu
beaucoup de dotations qui ont été faites
maintenant on passe à la vitesse
supérieure et on sait on a tous suivi ce
qui se passe avec le Danemark avec
évidemment aussi les Pays-Bas entre
autres Stéphane on parle de
l'intelligence artificielle oui en en
alors il été question à Davos en ce
moment en décembre l'Union européenne a
trouvé un accord pour encadrer le
développement de l'intelligence euh
artificielle c'est une a priori une très
bonne chose sauf que si l'Europe est le
seul à adopter ce ce type de de de de
d'encadrement est-ce que c'est pas de
nature à créé une distorsion dans la
recherche et le développement de l'
autrement dit est-ce que c'est pas un
risque pour nous de prendre du retard
sur d'autres en la matière je crois que
c'est contraire nous mettre en avance
c'est nous mettre en avance d'abord on
travaille sur ce sujet depuis maintenant
près de 5 ans donc c'est pas quelque
chose qui est si vous permettez cette
expression un peu triviale sortie du
chapeau comme toutes les régulations qui
ont été faites dans l'espace numérique
savez nous avons le le premier espace
numérique du monde libre 4 millions de
consommateurs pour nos téléspectateurs
je le elle on le sait mais c'est 330
millions les États-Unis nous sommes une
démocratie qui est une fois et demi plus
importante que la démocratie américaine
et nous sommes un marché intérieur qui
est une fois et demi plus important que
le marché américain de consommateurs 330
millions d'un côté 450 millions de
l'autre et pour le monde numérique on
sait qu'on compte souvent ça en comme on
dit en anglais en iceball hein
c'est-à-dire la capacité donc de de
pouvoir interagir c'est donc c'est donc
ça le marché intérieur numérique
aujourd'hui européen grâce aux
régulations que nous avons mis en place
j'ai toujours entendu ça au début les
Américains étaient les premiers à dire
non faites pas une régulation parce que
vous allez empêcher l'innovation et puis
après ça il vient ils viennent pour nous
remercier de l'avoir faite parce que il
n'arrive pas à la faire parce que c'est
très compliqué de ça leur permet de
faire la même chose donc je connais la
musique je connais les lobis mais nous
voyez on est là pour protéger nos
concitoyens c'est notre rôle et c'est
mon travail derrière pour les
entreprises derrière pour les entreprise
c'est très important de savoir aussi
surtout dans cet espace au fond ce
qu'elles peuTent faire et ce qu'ell
peuut faire faire il faut faire la
distinction entre la recherche et
développement et le marché intérieur la
pénétration du marché intérieur sur la
régulation de l'intelligence
artificielle il y a aucune contrainte
pour la recherche et développement zéro
d'accord ça veut donc dire que et
c'était quelque chose qui était très
important j'en ai beaucoup parlé
évidemment avec l'ensemble des
étatsmembres et en particulier avec le
gouvernement français c'était une
demande explicite du président de la
République elle a été respectée il avait
raison donc zéro je veux juste terminer
c'est très important zéro contrainte sur
la recherche développement et au
contraire vous venez en Europe vous
allez avoir en plus un accès et dans
certains cas gratuit à la puissance de
calcul on met tout le réseau des super
calculateurs il y en a 8 eurohpc le plus
important réseau de puissance de calcul
au monde à destination des start-ups qui
vont vouloir venir entraîner leur modèle
en Europe on sait que c'est un élément
absolument clé deuxième élément il faut
évidemment derrière encadrer les risques
alors ça ça n'a rien à voir et si vous
voulez rentrer ensuite sur le marché
intérieur avoir le bénéfice d'y rentrer
quelques soit encore l'origine où vous
avez créé vous avez innové il y a un
certain nombre de contraintes quand on a
des très grands modèles parce que il y a
des choses qu'on fait qu'on a pas le
droit de faire par exemple qu'on a'ura
pas le droit de faire en Europe par
exemple ce qu'on appelle le social
scoring c'est-à-dire regardez exactement
qui vous êtes pour dire en fonction de
ce que vous avez fait dans votre vie on
a tout stocké vous avez le droit d'être
médecin vous avez pas le droit vous avez
droit d'être professeur vous avez pas le
droit vous avez le droit de voyager vous
avez pas le droit suivez mon regard
c'est ce qui se passe en Chine ça ce
sera interdit pour la santé il y aura
des éléments de contrôle un petit peu en
amont quel que soit encore l'origine où
vous avez créé votre application
d'intelligence artif vcel donc on met
juste un certain nombre d'éléments pour
encadrer les risques éventuels mais je
le redis zéro pour l'innovation et la
recherche sboton on le voit depuis 20
minutes vous avez une vision des
ambitions pour l'Europe on est à 5 mois
des élections présidentielles la
majorité présidentielle n'a toujours pas
de tête de liste est-ce que vous avez
envie d'être celle non mais j'ai j'ai
déjà répondu à mareprise à cette
question quand on est dans ces fonctions
d'abord c'est pas des envies ou ou ou ou
ou des non envies on est là pour servir
moi j'ai dit de façon extrêmement claire
que ça ne marche pas comme ça on est pas
candidat à ce type de fonction en tout
cas moi avec l'expérience qui est la
mienne je l'ai appris depuis bien
longtemps mais est-ce que vous avez été
sollicité par pas je on n pas candidat
d'abord si j'avais été sollicité je vous
le diraiis pas et ensuite euh euh ça se
passe vous l'avez vu je crois y compris
à l'occasion j'ai cru comprendre qu'il y
avait eu un remanement en France il y a
il y a peu de temps vous avez compris
comment ça marche en politique j'ai un
tout petit peu d'expérience politique
comme vous savez j'ai toujours vu que ça
se passe généralement dans les dernières
minutes sur la finish
line c'est pas l'heure après l'heure non
plus ben voilà l'heure n'est pas encore
n'est pas encore venu et je le dis
encore une fois de façon extrêmement
claire c'est évidemment le président de
la République le chef de la majorité qui
décideront et moi de là où je suis et de
là où je serai je ferai tout évidemment
pour aider pour aider ce choix gag un
romanimement que la majorité
présidentielle a perdu sa probable tête
de list Stéphan sesjourné et que du coup
la donne a changé depuis que vous vous
êtes exprimé j'ai bien compris que vous
n'étiez pas candidat je repose ma
question autrement est-ce que si
Emmanuel Macron vous appelle et vous
demande de porter la liste vous lui
dites ouic et bien écoutez on verra
voilà comme mais mais par définition
jamais personne ne ferme la porte quand
le président de la République je suis
bien placé pour le savoir j'étais pas
prévu pour être commissaire repain je
suis extrêmement heureux de l'être vous
savez que je sais comment ça se passe ça
s'est passé aussi de la même façon
lorsque j'ai évidemment accepté
l'honneur que m'avait fait Jacques
Chirac en me demandant d'être ministre
des Finances donc je sais comment ça se
passe juste une précision Stéphane
séjourné ministre de l'Europe et des
Affaires étrangères c'est très bien en
même temps c'est le le groupe renew au
Parlement européen qui perd son
président or c'est un poste clé dans ce
Parlement est-ce que c'est pas aussi le
risque de de perdre pour la France de
perdre en influence au sein de au sein
des bon d'abord on d'abord on est à on
est à 4re points d' renouvellement voilà
on n pas on est pas on on n pas au
milieu de de de la mandature donc ce
serait bien à nouveau avoir un président
français ou je tiens à dire là je parle
évidemment au nom de ma famille
politique mais aussi en en tant
qu'observateur alors vous allez
peut-être dire que je suis un peu
orienté mais que Stéphan sjourné a fait
un travail absolument remarquable au
Parlement européen il a su fédérer notre
famille politique et cette fédération
elle existe elle existe elle est là donc
maintenant pour les trois ou 4re mois
qui restent le groupe du Parlement
européen je peux pas parler en son nom
mais je je je vois je sais qu'il va
choisir son ou sa leader euh il y a
évidemment des des personnes de très
grande qualité dans le dans dans le
groupe c'est important vous avez raison
on est un groupe très important au
Parlement européen le Parlement européen
a joue un rôle extrêmement important ça
me permet de le dire précisément pour
façonner ces lois qui sont importantes
je parlais des lois du numérique elles
ont été façonnées au Parlement européen
ça change notre vie et le groupe
renu joue un rôle absolument majeur par
parenthèse les groupes extrêmes
s'extraient de toutes les discussions
donc je vois que je porte pas de
jugement je ne veux encore stigmatiser
personne mais je tiens
à porter témoignage que pour les groupes
extrêmes il ne joue jamais aucun rôle
dans les lois qui vont ensuite jouer un
rôle positif pour pour nos concitoyens
européens maintenant sur le groupe renu
euh dans dans dans dans les jours qui
viennent il y aura évidemment un nouveau
leader qui sera qui sera désigné et et
et le groupe ira à la bataille et
compris avec son spiton candidat le
tempsf le groupe Ren qui devrait aussi
choisir un candidat pour la présidence
de la Commission européenne vous
pourriez être celui-là ah bah ça ça là
c'est un autre
sujet il appartient saz les les les la
façon dont ça se passe c'est les chefs
d'État et de gouvernement qui vont
d'abord désigner ensuite qui pourrait
être le ou Laou ou la candidate vous
avez vu que là encore ça s'était fait je
dirais pour le dernier choix sur V
derlen dans les dernières 24 heures les
choses et après et après il faut que
celui ou celle qui est désigné euh et le
soutien du Parlement et c'est pas c'est
pas toujours facile c'est notre
démocratie nous sommes dans une grande
démocratie continentale mais ça vous
intéresse mais ce qui m'intéresse c'est
de servir l'Europe vous l'avez compris
merci Thierry Breton merci beaucoup
d'avoir été notre invité ce matin
Stéphane vous restez avec nous on passe
tout de suite au club des territoires